people are calling it Nature's ozempic
I've got
I've gone and over a thousand type 2
diabetes patients found that when
compared to Lifestyle modification or a
placebo berberine did reduce blood sugar
and blood lipids it wasn't necessarily
better than oral medications like
metformin on its own but when they were
combined there was a significant
Improvement as for weight loss one
larger view of the literature found that
berberine moderately but significantly
did reduce weight and waist
circumference so there's no denying that
in the world of supplements berberine is
pretty powerful stuff but I still would
never liken it to the current All-Star
anti-obesity agents like ozempic if an
influencer is trying to convince you
that you can get the same exact results
from an herb as you can from a powerful
pharmaceutical it's probably a really
big red flag next